so cocky boo when can we expect the
trailer how's it going everybody
so yesterday Joe Russo director along
with his brother Anthony Russo of
infinity war and Avengers 4 took over do
ellos Instagram and duello is a bar that
he owns part of duello had a live Q&A
with Joe Russo we're Avengers fans
Marvel fans could ask any questions that
they wanted to him and of course one of
the questions that one of the fans asked
was when can we expect to see the
Avengers 4 trailer my giveaway still
continues giving away copies of infinity
war Deadpool 2 and ant-man and the wasp
on blu-ray as well as some special
edition posters all you have to do to
enter for your chance to win is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
here's what Joe Russo had to say to the
question when will we see the Avengers 4
trailer
or may not see it before the calendar
so as you can see Joe Russo kind of
trolled everybody his answer was that we
may or may not see it before the
calendar turns to 2019
a lot of people are taking this as we
are not going to see the trailer until
2019 that is not necessarily the case I
mentioned it in a video yesterday and
you have to keep in mind that everything
is super strategic with Marvel with
Kevin Feige with the Russo brothers
everything is done on purpose yes Joe
Russo used this to promote his bar
absolutely there is nothing wrong with
that at all but he knew that this was
for the most part going to be an
Avengers for QA and he knew that for
sure two questions were going to be
asked one when are we going to see the
trailer and two what is the title so Joe
had already thought about what he was
going to say when somebody asked him
when we'd see the trailer for Avengers 4
he already knew his answer he already
knew what he was going to say to not
really give anything away that's just
how the Russo brothers are remember how
much they trolled us with Avengers
infinity war
and let's not forget that Kevin Feige
himself said that we'd get the trailer
before 2019 now of course things pop up
and it can get delayed and things can
change
but again Kevin Feige said it was coming
out before 2019 the Russo brothers are
kings at trolling people and November
29th marks the one-year mark since the
Avengers infinity war trailer came out
for the very first time and again
outside sources such as the
international trailer source said that
the trailer would be coming out in
November so a lot points to us getting
the trailer at this year but what do you
all think do you think that we're going
to get it this year next year do you
think that Joe Russo is just trolling us
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to
Avengers 4 as always thank you so much
for watching woof woof
[Music]